cessez le feu a été annoncée par par le
maire de la ville ce matin il entrera en
vigueur ce soir et pour 36 heures on va
faire un point sur l'état d'avancée
d'efforts se ruent sur la stratégie de
moscou toujours avec vous mathieu
mabanckou jean-mathieu d'ordinaire notre
correspondant à washington de passage
par nos plateaux à paris alors un mot
peut-être de kiev tout d'abord où
évidemment l'attention se concentre
aujourd'hui l'opération rue se fait à
plusieurs niveaux il ya on vient de le
voir des bombardements alliés aussi les
frappe venue du seuil l'opération
thérèse dont on dit qu'elle se renforce
est il juste comme on entend le dire
depuis le début de cette guerre que la
capitale est encerclée par les troupes
russes non ça n'est pas juste absolument
pas lorsqu'on entend ça en réalité il
faut en déduire la perception d'abord
que les ukrainiens peuvent en avoir et
notamment les habitants de kiev qui
peuvent éprouver cette sensation de
sièges inévitablement qui est notamment
renforcé par les frappes aériennes et
les frappes d'artillerie qui touche les
abords nord ouest de la capitale on le
voit pas distinctement sur cette carte
mais effectivement il ya un axe d'effort
ici qui est opéré par des troupes russes
notamment venant du bélarus au nord
ouest de la capitale qui tend à se
renforcer effectivement et on voit
également de quelques escarmouches à
l'est de la ville pour l'instant mais l
axe d'effort est bel et bien au nord
ouest de la capitale il n'est pas
question de parler d'encerclement tout
simplement parce que ça n'est pas à la
portée du contingent russe qui a
l'intention de s'emparer du pays il
faudrait des forces absolument
considérable supérieure en nombre à
celles que possèdent les russes au
moment où nous parlons pour pouvoir
organiser l'encerclement puis le siège
de la capitale ce qui en plus prendrait
des mois et ne représenterait pas
d'intérêt tactique l'intention de
vladimir poutine s'est bel et bien de
s'emparer de la capitale de l'ukraine et
de son chef ça ça fait plus beaucoup de
secrets pour personne en tout cas le
pentagone a annoncé de manière claire
nette et précise dès le début de
l'opération donc non pas d'encerclement
en revanche une volonté de pénétrer à
l'intérieur de la capitale et le sang en
paraissant paraît si possible puis ça on
a entendu beaucoup de choses à ce niveau
là on dit l'ampleur de la ville à taille
de pierre rend les opérations
extrêmement compliqué pour les russes au
point que certains estiment que ça va
être très compliqué pour les russes ça
va être compliqué d'entrer et d'y rester
ensuite ça va être compliqué ça va être
long ça va être très consommateur en
hommes et en vies humaines clairement et
notamment pour le contingent qui va
devoir s'emparer de la ville par son
contingent russe évidemment mais je
dirais que oui c'est possible car
l'objectif n'est pas de s'emparer de
chaque maison de chaque rue de chaque
quartier et l'objectif est bel et bien
de gares et les chars de vladimir
poutine les chars de moscou sur cette
place devant le palais présidentiel de
son parent et des symboles du pouvoir et
si possible de s'emparer du chef de
l'état encore une fois c'est une
intention qui a clairement été
identifiés par le renseignement
américain qui sait que c'était
l'objectif initial de vladimir poutine
un objectif qui était poursuivi par le
président russe au cours de la première
semaine de l'offensive qu'il voulait on
le sait être une offensive éclair son
plan n'a pour le moment pas fonctionné
ça ne veut pas dire que son plan ne
fonctionnera pas à terme encore une fois
le temps tactique n'est pas le temps
médiatique évidemment qu'il ya une
supériorité militaire et numériques
russe qui finira tôt ou tard par payer